it's the sort of public event that
should be impossible in a pandemic but
millions of South Koreans have gone to
the polls the first national elections
to be held in an infected country I
thought the election would be postponed
so I was very worried since it took
place as scheduled wearing gloves and
keeping a distance from other people
were not that difficult and I saw many
staff working hard for voters this is
our first time as we are suffering from
coronavirus and I think it was a good
choice to open here if people in self
quarantine take safety measures I don't
think we need to worry too much the
government have said that keeping your
distance is important and they will wear
a face mask so I'm not that worried
about them coming to vote this hasn't
been an entirely typical campaign
kissing babies is off the cards even if
social distancing hasn't quite been
observed early voting was held on Friday
and Saturday so the crowds wouldn't be
concentrated on just one day president
moon jaein was among those to cast an
early ballot public support for the
government's handling of the crisis is
likely to leave this party in control at
the National Assembly today voters had
to wear masks have their temperature
checked disinfect their hands then
donned gloves before entering the
polling booth all the time keeping one
meter apart the background is South
Korea's extensive testing tracing and
quarantine measures which means the
country has recorded fewer than 250
deaths from covert 19 as a result
authorities felt the elections could go
ahead safely according to Professor John
Joachim a specialist in infectious
disease is involved in screening cases
[Music]
even helps to detect
they are and whether they are keeping
their isolation strategies at home or
not the source of mesh is being applied
in countries around East Asia and
letting people return to a more or less
normal life-- they start at a border
where governments like Taiwan South
Korea Japan and China have all imposed
strict controls and quarantines here in
Beijing they don't have to worry about
democratic elections but they're still
making use of new tools to keep a
watchful eye on the population and guard
against coronavirus outbreaks face masks
pretty much compulsory everywhere you've
also got the ubiquitous timber checks
but then there's this as well so this is
an app it's run by the Chinese
government and it gives you a pass this
means green arm okay to go and that's
based on Michael education data so I
just show the guy do that today's
election in South Korea was remarkable
visual proof that democracy's not just
authoritarian regimes in weather
coronavirus their success is worth
studying tools and techniques that might
be useful for posted lockdown in UK
whenever that may be
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing